um
um maybe to to describe the philosophy
of this of of this Workshop you know I
should go back to there were uh there
was a play by Anna De via Smith where
she uh where she quoted or actually
acted out of course uh
um and uh an astronomer from MIT a
professor of astronomy from MIT
describing how you
how you try to look at very distant
objects and he said the main idea is you
know the the big thing you do is you
have to create a mirror as large as
possible
because
and it doesn't matter you know it's
small and they'll always be
imperfections but if you have a large
enough mirror then you can then you can
really uh
uh you know tell very small differences
apart and
in this case you know the again you know
when when you're trying to understand
something difficult it is it's really
helpful to have have a you know have a
very large numbers of points points of
view juxtaposed
in a in a way where there's a there's a
there's a lot of discussion and so that
brings me to the
to the to the final point about this
which is uh which is that um
uh one of the rules that we use for for
some workshops here at the Science
Institute is discussion Trump's schedule
now
that's your point yes so so uh and you
know unfortunately uh for you know in
this case there was a there was a lot to
cover there are many speakers the
schedule is more full than we'd have
liked um but even so we've left you know
uh a third of the time you know
available uh to for speakers uh for
discussion so um so um feel free to ask
questions also during the during the
talks uh they'll be moderated by uh
session chairs so you know if there's
too much uh too many questions we'll try
to Tamp it down but uh but but
discussions are there you know so
um you know we have a great set of
speakers but also the audience is is a
is an integral part of this Workshop
okay and um
um
uh let's see um uh two two two more
points before I before I stop there's a
there's a session on Friday afternoon
for uh for contributed talks so if you'd
like to contribute a talk there'll be
there'll be uh a way to do that on the
conference web on the Workshop web page
by this evening so and these will be
short talks between 55 and 20 minutes so
uh okay and then finally uh I should say
that uh seems like
there is
uh finally the beginnings of covet in
there so if you wish to there are masks
at the front desk if you want to mask up
okay okay so let's uh let's start with
the first first talk uh by internally at
Microsoft research so uh I you know I
know Ian thought for a long time has uh
you know as one of the brilliant leading
uh algorithms design uh uh designers and
but over the last few years he's uh he's
transition to uh to machine learning uh
showing some presence and doing so and
he'll tell us he was on the Sparks paper
and he'll also tell us about uh smaller
models that he's been training that to
quote generation
foreign
yeah
can you hear
[Applause]
yeah I have been
supportive for assignments you can see
this is a decision many years ago and
usually I come here as an expert for
example I come here as a mathematician
talking about lock concave distribution
or come here as as Optimizer talking
about linear program but this time I
really come to talk about something I
don't really understand and so I'm
really privileged about this uh
yeah and and I start to talk with this
poll just to see how many people have
been using GPT for and
and yeah I guess
almost everyone is using GPT for now so
so I guess first part of toy is kind of
unnecessary this talk has two parts one
one part is the specs of you must ask me
to present and DNA parties a smaller
model we are trying to change
uh
yeah so I guess
where is my mouse
yeah so this is the the first part is
just some early experiment with gpd4 and
I won't write my conclusion here but I
guess everyone here almost everyone here
already using GPS also so you know what
is my conclusion and and but essentially
we really like gpd4 so we asked a
lateral question can we get a GP T4 ish
stuff much smaller and cheaper to train
and and turns out you can get a pretty
good coding model from scratch using
just three thousand dollars this is not
a buy two model but training from
scratch
uh yeah this this two picture is is
created by AI this is gpd4
0 lies uh
and and both talk order co-oper is from
Microsoft
for the first one oh by the way if you
have any question about
anything just stop me feel free to stop
me
so we are really grateful for open AI
giving us access to gpd4 the the version
we have SS is some earlier version we've
done our experiment around October last
year this is a funny time because this
is before the announcement of GPD 3.5 so
when we are testing for written ethernet
access at 3.5 the chat GPT and so at
that time the
we it both are my even greater because
we the previous version of GPT is free
and that version is not that good so
this is a really huge one for us
and the model we assess at that time is
still being changing and it has less
instruction fine tune
so it will answer any question you ask
and it is test only model so at that
time they haven't fighting with the
image
and at that time before this the only
model we know is stupid freezer and and
for us refriger3 is like a model just
can copy and pay some style or something
so we start with a very mild goal we
want to see
can we at least show some examples
usually before it's doing something
Beyond copy and paste that is what we
think at that time and it completely
blows my mind
uh but but but I guess the main question
is how can we tell whether the model is
copy and paste we don't have very
scientific approach so what we do is we
just add some very creative question we
try to come up with something we we
lived a lot on the internet although
after our paper is online many people
post up manifesting your asses on the
internet
so but this is a tough question uh
so we start with some some tasks that is
that is unfair to gpd4 remember the
model we test is a test only model it
only with tests so you can bring it as a
five people for his whole life and then
we as it can do pretty for sure so this
can anyone guess what is this picture
this is a picture by some fine people
uh yeah this is this is a cat
uh so so I'm just giving this as a base
level a human can do if he can never can
see
and so we asked GPT for sure unicorn
probably many of you have already seen
that unicorn
uh so we asked to pd4 to draw a unicorn
and this is what we get
although this doesn't look nice but but
this is still crazy
only we test so it learned about latest
with the whole archive it will it have
with many Wikipedia articles it knows a
unicorn maybe you know unicorn have four
legs and something but maybe he don't
know there has to be above the body
where that that knowledge come from or
maybe he doesn't know maybe the course
will be there instead of there and and
also remember this is drawn by taxi and
if you try to draw a picture on Taxi
it's very difficult you need to specify
each coordinate of each circle where is
that so even
able to draw two circle touching is
already some math inside and but it
turns out can draw how beautiful is
unicorn
yeah I think I should try to draw myself
I don't think I can draw that good
without trial era
any question about your account uh
yeah yeah yeah yes something is not
touching
oh
yeah yeah honestly I don't know why it's
unicorn look like uh maybe my my son
know better
we try manifest oh yeah in fact the
first thing we try is the Pokemon
but for copyright reason we love posting
but but it look look like a pocket mode
Pikachu
yeah yeah yeah we we noticed that after
two people is online uh but but at least
this look horrible so I think it's more
realistically love copying because it is
horrible
but yeah then after we see this then we
are debating with my colleagues of like
okay uh we are debating with Carly is
that copying from the Internet or
enjoying on its own and for myself I'm
pretty sure this is real because
it's horrible but but some quality don't
believe
and so so then we need to test is this
copy so the the thing we test is this uh
how about if if we look at the taxi code
in general we remove all command the
command is very good where is the
headways the body so it's a good code we
remove all commands we randomly promise
some coordinate just to make sure it's
not copying and we remove the horn and
ask him to and give the protected code
to GPT and ask it to draw better horn
and he is uh you see the link is move
around so this is not the original
unicorn and you're able to draw the horn
uh so so at least it no it's
not only
are you able to understand unicorn we
also do other tests like we give it some
picture asking what is that and
sometimes it can do and sometimes it
can't but
but if the diagram is simple enough
usually you can
and so so I think this is a pretty good
evidence it's a lot
just copying from the internet
and and remember when we are testing the
GPT 40 is still ongoing training so we
we can pass it again again to see how
the Unicorn change over time if it is
changing them we know
it is popular copying so this is free
Recon two weeks apart
you can see there is the magic of
changing is happening the Unicorn
becomes better and better and and this
is look really really nice although the
middle one live pack uh
wait what
why did it become better or what it is
no no no yes the model is
no no no the model is still on ongoing
chiangle oh training yeah yeah
they they I I I don't exactly you know
what they're doing they either doing the
preaching namely within the whole
internet or they have doing fine tuning
some human interesting and answer just
to make sure it understands interesting
[Music]
but they they they're doing those things
but I don't know at that time what is
what they are doing
did they use your unicorn instructions
no no they don't know about you they
can't instruction
one week before we put the paper online
otherwise it's not fair
uh but but then you may ask voice to
you're the kind of like this is October
November
and and after our paper online there's
different website about hourly update of
unicorn and the daily update of unicorn
I cannot open the hourly update because
when I open it my browser would crash
there is too many images
so this is uh
daily update of unicorn
uh is horrible
uh but but roughly speaking the reason
is after the power the model is is
perfect they lead to compress it sound
to make it easier to to to one and after
compressing then you come
becomes more like oh human
drawing
oh yeah and and certainly we test if we
can draw 2D about 3D this is not precise
from the problem is longer but we just
we just try to come up some combination
that cannot be on the internet some
falling Island water for which Castle
fighting dragon and Island now Olympic
wing uh anyone see the Olympic ring uh
yeah there's some some color of Olympus
there
um yeah and this isn't some 3D scripting
language yeah I asked him to wire HTML
I I didn't know HTML can do this before
but
but apparently you can do anything in
HTML now
so so at least at least for this part of
the experiment I feel AI is already kind
of human age or Beyond human depends on
who you are at least for me I cannot
draw anything that is beyond me
and and and also remember usually when
human draw withdraw especially for doing
taxi we type some code and then see the
result and then modify your code and see
the result
but the AI can never see the results so
I can see the result and pick a good one
but at least it's way more difficult and
unfair
yeah so so this is drawing
uh but but but the real
real application of gpt4 is coding so we
do some very simple tests uh
uh so in the league league website they
have some uh interview exercise for
people doing for different company
interview so we give him Amazon
interview this is a two hour
interference in four minutes it takes
four minutes because we need to copy and
paste to the AI of the pressing uh and
and it gets 100 correct
uh but this is a lot of good test
because we don't really know whether
those maybe those are just standard
interview tests and he can copy from the
internet so can we come up with
something that
that you cannot copy so so what I do is
this I just come up with some random
game and ask it to to do I try to make
it more Microsoft
why be a physics game using JavaScript
is a 3D game the winner is a Microsoft
logo and from time to time there's a
board job to the arena uh the color of
the boy is one of the color of Microsoft
logo and then you start with five live
and still score if the ball hit the
winner the power disappeared
if the color doesn't match you lose one
knife if it match you get 10 score and
and you can remove a ball by kicking it
until you came over right in HTML
so this
I don't know for professional program
how long it takes to do this uh unlock a
professional programmer but but you can
play the game game here wait
ing this game is very important let me
yeah so this is the game you can see I
can barely play again this game will go
faster and faster so this this is uh
visible game to pay you can pay off live
but eventually you will notice because
it's too fast uh but uh this this game I
have something like 500 live of code you
cannot add the source code yourself I
also write down the precise form I give
in the source code so you can just take
a look uh
so I have a question so that's
interesting
um the way you specify the game you said
what you want to happen in it right yeah
I suppose you wanted to say something
like I want to
uh come up with a game that would test
whether
[Music]
um
with a multitasking ability wow
something that has two tasks at least uh
and the people who are better at doing
you know two tasks yeah yeah you're okay
of an idea rather than like step by step
what you want to happen again yeah if
you ask him something more open-ended
then you will end up getting some more
standard results standard namely if if
there is some game in the internet
satisfied that and he will start spread
out those things
that's why we try to lock open-ended
also when it is too open-ended usually
you get very simple results but but I'll
go is to
look more impressive but in terms of the
fact that you are arguing that this is
uh
how you're trying to measure whether
this is as intelligent as yeah
I don't know what a program is oh yeah
yeah no no I think for open-end the gpt4
is less good than humans
by a large margin
uh it is good at email taking something
on the internet but
it doesn't really
I don't know I'm just curious about you
real quick about asking you forget to
is that a reasonable
proxy in your opinion
to what you would expect an intelligent
yeah I know I I agree for human
certainly a more open anything that he
can really showcase what is strength
seems like something where you could
just get like some collider from the
internet on how to do a bottom and a lot
of other side of the internet that
Mexico together to get this game yeah
but did you try something like
um more math style for like example from
Led programming questions that are
helping the internet oh yeah yeah we did
we did some
oh at that
time we take 100 latest questions I
asked to gpt4 and the performance is
about the human level
but the questions that you got were not
yeah and so Nico every week have a
competition we assume those at New
Classic yeah yeah
I would bring
yeah uh so so so far so good uh gpt4 is
pretty good so now I start give
something that is horrible for qpt live
math so at least we still have some ads
uh so one the
my mouse is gone
okay
my computer is freezing
okay uh so one what is the best way to
test human about math is doing a
one-to-one interview
we have
since my slice
is locked
I already closed the game
maybe is the website maybe I calls
everything
wow
let's play some delay
what
interesting my my keyboard is not
working but my mouse is working it's
fine uh
so one one best way to test human in
math is two one or one interview in our
team that is a famous mathematician
golden there and so we asked him to
interview
the GPT for he is also an offer of both
of the paper so we so he he tried to
interview gpd4 as is a new company
Master since you're going to see if he
would hire that still doing
so this is what he asked and can you
remind me what his case k set form and
yeah this is simple it's just a
definition and then can you remind me
what is the office way to solve a case
set this is also simple it's just too
fast and then but but to really test if
someone understands math then we want to
combine between different concepts in
math
so
so we uh
we do this uh
so for application he defines some graph
associated with the case at something
like each variable corresponding to a
vertex in the graph and then you ask
what if the graph is disconnected how
fast you can solve a case set
uh according to all that he finds those
questions is Neil he come up with
himself so he don't believe he is on the
internet and
but but at least this is the question
and then and then and then gp2 for
answer currently you can if the graph is
disconnected they are just two
independent copy of case that you can
solve them separately so so far so good
uh
and then
if you remove one Edge it will become
disconnected how can you solve it and
gpt4 is is also correct you say you just
put first on that edge and then solve
the problem separately on both
so those skill collab and according to
all that you pass the test for for
master student
uh
but but then the whole thing is but then
if if the interview is five minutes the
pt4 can pass it but if the interview is
one hour the echo Hall 21 after you
continue to ask yourself realize she may
not even understand what is the question
or have some completely nonsense output
uh we just give one complete nonsense
here
uh this is a simple question just to
make sure everyone understand the
question
we have a decreasing seven times four
plus eight times eight is ninety two can
you change one number such as the output
is 106.
so this is uh I don't know which level
is this uh maybe Middle School
and then let's see and in case you
cannot solve uh the answer is you can
change four to six there and and the way
you try to solve it is you look at the
difference and try to come up with
something
and and then
but one thing Jupiter 4 is better is
remember what you those llm is doing is
trying to protecting letter by letter so
outputting something so it it doesn't
really do any planning or it cannot go
bad to fix this mistake so this question
is is a little bit tricky maybe the
first when your child may not work so
it's it leads some panning or some try
and error
and and this is what gpt4 give uh
yeah use it usually starts with some
sentences meaningless like that it feels
possible with at that time you'd like to
start with some meaningless sentence
like there's multiple way to solve a
problem and then you start writing down
the answer immediately imagine you're at
the gpt4 model you're generating descent
this has nothing to do with the question
it just repeating something and then the
first number is generating is already
is already
what's the equation must be called
otherwise it cannot go back
unfortunately it's generally the first
Lumber in correlate and and and then she
lose the game he just continues trying
to complete his sentence okay is 106 and
why because if you change seven tonight
and then you try to explain it it
mistake
and
for this one like uh if you do this now
it doesn't work yeah I I left when your
paper came out like half of the things
that that like didn't work in the paper
were fixed within two weeks oh you're
literally like two weeks after oh I oh
like all of the things that were like
okay I didn't know I didn't know oh but
but some of the examples in the slices
not on the paper does that work
so just um you know you say Okay so the
difficulty here you know the problem it
has is with planning so I find that the
little puzzling that it would have
trouble with planning here but when you
talk about satisfiability and the
bipartite graph and it's disconnected
that that it can answer that question
without planning or yeah
thoughts is the answer then it's easier
for gpd4
but it is very passive like for coding
how you can write everything correlative
without planning
I just tried it with the code
interpreter plug and it got it oh nice
so
there is could this be
it's more of X Paradox which says that
you know the the hard things are easy
and the easy things are hard
you know it's very hard to think and
very high dimension the same way it's
very hard to know what is on the
internet right so uh
in a lot of your examples you know I
don't know if it's on the Internet or
not and it seems like you actually do
want to figure this out to to really
know
what is actually generate what is
synthesized and what is coupled together
in this post-modernist uh hodgepodge
from from sources that are out there
yeah no no no ways of figuring
one way we try to do is to do our
experiment more intensively because when
we are paying with the model then it
brought up the capacity and
um and when we're playing with it we
realize it it seems to understand
something but if you pay long enough it
sometimes starts generating some error
and then everything after this nonsense
so it's basically like you know final
exams in in some for our students they
they do very well
and then you pull them into your office
and you realize that they don't
understand anything yeah
yeah you can bring it down
how do you know that it's not actually
doing anything in that initial prefix so
for example you tried changing some of
the numbers
I I didn't know what going on with this
as well but
yeah but but I think the the model have
two difficulty of any problem we require
more Panic at least this is consistent
at that time but maybe now I mean I mean
you're using the term planning but I
think a much simpler thing is just a
calculator oh yeah execute
yeah yeah we oh we try a more funny
experiment like this we ask it to
generate a story
uh the first word is the reverse of the
last word
then you really depending yeah and we
can never make it work at that time I
don't know now
you would probably need a scratch this
yeah yeah I just tried it it doesn't
work without the code interpreter so
what you're saying you did is you
actually yeah so so so so so actually
Ernie day Ernie Davis and I have a paper
on the archive from just last week where
we're trying a bunch of examples with
code interpreter and the Wolfram Alpha
plug it and we see very very clearly
that it can solve way more math problems
with the plugins than without them yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so is it possible that what's happened
so at each step it's creating a
distribution and sampling from that to
the next token is it possible that's
what's Happening Here is it just
randomly accidentally generated a nine
and then it has to justify its own
mistake because it can't go back but
there's an error of like it not being
deterministic more than anything oh yeah
yeah
you can bring it that way for example
for for many
famous bench Malai coding math if you
allow it to generate multiple answer and
pick the best one or ask it to choose
that then it will get way better
but I think the point is here that if
the only solution is to change the four
to a six then it never should have
any problem that's what I mean is is it
possible that this is a sort of the
error is coming from the fact that it's
not deterministic when it's come to
solve this more than it's not planning
but when we generally we usually choose
temperature is zero so it is
uh so in in all this you're you're
you're starting with this uh this
question you know is it um is it
remembering things on the Internet or is
it um you know it's actually
understanding that uh is are you does
that mean that you're you're starting
with this that the model is large enough
that that it could
principle remember the entire
time who's saying no I don't want to
make any conclusions
no no but what I'm saying is just in
terms of the size of the model uh is it
uh is is the is the assumption that you
can you know you can compress the
internet down to all its essential
content and the model is big enough
that's the that's the starting point
well starting from what that's the
biggest assumption here that um that in
fact the model is compressing the
internet down to you know that yeah that
it's big enough that it contains all the
yeah yeah certainly yeah
one thing I really like about the model
is they know who is entirely
who is in Italy
well but I mean if you don't give it a
calculator then I would say like its
ability to do arithmetic is about like
like what what you know what persons
would be while they're dreaming all
right
no no this is not that this is not about
characteristic this is about it is
trying to complete the sentence that can
it looked like co-ed if you change this
to any number this will reflection
mistake
mistaken oh no he's just he always
pretends he's called yeah yeah that's a
separate thing that it doesn't it
doesn't know what it doesn't know yeah
yeah
I think the current version of GPD boy
is opposite he always apologized even if
you point out something he is correct to
being Colette but this version is the is
a stalker version
thank you
oh yeah
so uh what if you just let it uh try a
couple of times and then it's like it's
like it doesn't appreciate that the last
uh thing is a hard rule like like you
have to modify exactly one integer
that's fine so it doesn't appreciate
that it needs to check it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
in general you have to form have only
one answer then
then it is not too good
actually going further to what you said
in my case
and said therefore with the provided
identity and constraints it is not
possible
so it has
been funny yeah so I guess we should
wait for wait for five
and when is that coming
I think you should ask him
I think he's allowed to say to
say though if if if if I knew or if
anyone knew that I wouldn't be allowed
to but yeah
but no I mean
no no I
agree if you do a lot of palm
engineering you'll be fine yeah we we
try but then they are a lot intelligent
they are human intelligence
language intelligence
yeah and
and I will be quicker here uh oh yeah
there is a lot of other weakness of GPT
for uh first of all it doesn't know the
latest thing like who is the president
at that time and then it cannot do
calculation as we discussed and it have
real trouble of doing electric hunting
uh
uh something why everyone can do it
cannot uh but but as
as God say you can solve it by giving
you some tools for example if it allows
it to search to calculation to to
contact them it knows how to use those
two after you tell him once you don't
need to fine tune it
um
yeah I
yeah honestly I don't really know what
is the conclusion of this review maybe
is this a HEI I would say this
intelligent but not human I I personally
believe it is doing more than copy and
paste uh especially for every like
clothing although maybe some people
still uh
a lot agreeing and and when we always
see it cannot do math in multiple ways
uh especially it cannot prove anything
uh
but for me I think the the real
my the real thought I have is it doesn't
fully matter uh
is incredibly useful I'm using this
daily for coding for this this is a
better than search engine and I can use
that for watching recommendation letter
writing Grand proposal Grand report or
whatever
uh it it the GPT for English is way
better than me
very importantly
they have to start
remember one thing is scale metal loss
this is for picture about a map of us
made of sushi
of some image model of different scale
and you can see clearly stay some
improvement there
and I think when I was in high school I
saw this picture in Wikipedia
at that time I kind of finished nonsense
because
I think the key difficulty of the
intelligence should be what is the
program no one can seems at that time
since every program is useful for us and
how can you put force a human brain at
least at that time I think in that way
and the this process happens in 2000 and
and amazingly if you look at prediction
at this time the Forbes is correct
um and and according to this part we're
getting close to human brain maybe you
know one or two years I don't know how
how accurate is this reducing 20 years
ago but but this is kind of a crazy
position at that time I would think this
is just crazy but but now I still think
it's crazy in a different way
so this is the first part of the talk
and I think oh I think I have
certificate
uh
so oh yeah after playing with the giant
error and then what we talk about some
small llma yellow app
uh so this this is a paper called
textbook all your latest it's just some
catchy title uh again this John work
with a team Microsoft what we're trying
to solve is this uh simple question our
goal is to get a one I don't
I think the GPT for size
but our goal is to get one billion size
model for coding this is maybe 100 or a
thousand or very large better or from
GT4 and we want to solve this type of
question this is a huge human evolution
Benchmark from open AI The Benchmark is
like this you're given the definition of
function with some description what it
does and I output I'll put the code for
you so this is a code completion
uh some questions in the some questions
in the human evalu is very simple and
something is very difficult
uh
and and as people from the company
theoretical company science I really
like making a giant table so this is the
giant table this is a progress on this
Benchmark after it is it is online you
can see some things here for example you
can see something like
model size matter a lot for 300 million
size model you get 12 16 billion you get
40 to model size matter a lot for this
model for this form it's not a cheerful
tasks you can solve at that time with a
small size model
and also if you look at all the model we
know tabular size
before before this summer the best
results is
30-ish percent
um and so and and also you you see here
uh so when you talking about changing
there is two parameters that is
important one is the size one is how
large is the data set you can say see
many of them is 100 billion size
and and the model we create is this uh
with one billion size less than 10
billion data sets and our accuracy is uh
more than 50 percent
and and we also tested a bench matches
to make sure we are not overfitting to
one one Benchmark and the result is
still stay off the art except gpd4 and
3.5
uh
so at least it shows maybe we are doing
something
so I will just discuss what we did uh
so to to to get large language model the
basically the only thing you link is a
data set so a standard data set is
a source code from GitHub is two
terabyte size
uh it's too too large for our budget we
don't really have budget but we don't
really have GPU to use to change a model
uh so and and also if you look at the
data set it kind of long sense uh if you
want to sample a page from GitHub this
is what you get uh something uh yeah
it's Lockwood
as a as an example in the textbook you
just get a bunch of
random stuff
but whoa and but if you look at the data
set more closely maybe one percent of
the data look like this
at least something seems to teaching you
something how to normalize the weather
then you do something and how to compute
the distance it tell you something so
our first thinking is maybe we should
just bring lym as a human if we want to
teach a human we shouldn't just feed a
random video from YouTube instead of mob
more like textbook so what we do is we
try to filter the GitHub according to
its educational value and nowadays if
you have a complicated NLP task you
don't know how to do that you can ask
your pt4 254 can classify whether the
document is have education value or
losses fertilized unfortunately if you
just use this to classify the whole
stack on the python it will take a
million so it's a lot like uh
so we do the most natural thing we just
label say 10 000 document and use that
to change a classifier and then use the
classifier to label the whole GitHub
then then it takes very small cost
and then we pick the top 20 of the
GitHub
and and but when we look at the the
result we see some of the topic that I'm
really covered by the GitHub source code
and some topic is over presented for
example it has so many python websites
and yeah this is just a lot of good
distribution so we asked you PT 3.5 to
generate
1 billion size of textbook
uh at the reason we pick 3.5 instead of
four is because of budget is super
expensive for stupid people to generate
a bunch of textbook
um and and and after our paper is done
we finally look at what we generated in
those textbooks and we found out they
are full of mistakes
but whatever we already done the chain
link uh and turns out the result is fine
so so maybe if you use four then your
result will be better but you need a
better budget
uh so that was uh what the textbook look
like for example this one is teaching
you about SVT
uh some some tests and some called
mixture
and then we call this we call both the
filtered
GitHub and the textbook as the data set
called textbook
and um
this project is kind of inspired by the
Thailand story done by Walden and
they try to come up with a language
model that is good at writing story and
they found out turns out you just need
10 million size model to do that if your
data is good enough
um I feel like the result in NLP that if
you like train from a larger model makes
your model good I've been like
rediscovered again and again
but like you couldn't do this unless you
had GP three points yeah yeah this is a
tough question
it'll be nice if I can do an experiment
of downloading every python textbook in
the internet and then change a model but
they have real copyright issue
I I suspect you
spell your only popular repos or
something yeah but but if you look at
those popular reports there is still a
maybe more than 90 of the code is some
repeated
pattern I mean it's not I would take the
negative on your bed
um
if you want to try that I would take the
negative but if you downloaded textbooks
yeah but yeah I could yeah I could try
private textbook but I think I cannot do
that as a Microsoft employee join open
AI
well by the statue I think no I think
open there cannot do that they are
getting lawsuit for this type of thing
no no that I believe it will work if but
I can
yeah yeah but if you're academic you can
do this is just few thousand dollars and
and there is some websites containing
every textbook in the world in some
Russian websites sure you can try I I
cannot
I try to go to those websites bought by
Microsoft Internet but you get my
hypothesis
7.5 yeah no I understand what you say uh
but
I don't know
I mean it's a very interesting question
right if you read a textbook and you
train the weights of your brain you know
the fact that you use that is that is
that pirating
yeah this is also a legal question
just use the the six billion
the performance
uh yeah
it oh that it is locked on the slides uh
there is still I understand
uh this is not the most important part
so it's difficult to answer
uh
the database from uh like code forces or
where there's like problems and then
uh yeah yeah we did that experiment and
but we realized it doesn't help because
turns out
five percent of GitHub is still strength
so it is already repeated
and so this this is not the whole store
honestly I don't know why the the result
model is good but this is not the whole
story so so remember I want that time
the best 10 million size model is
Advantage accuracy so we are we are
already pretty good at that time with
just a bunch of textbooks
um
and also against scales matter
300 million versus 1 billion you see a
large difference
uh we
and then but then
but then you can think we're just trying
to change our LM as it's a human the
ideal thing is we intellectively talking
with the model for for for 10 decades
and then it will be better but today is
impossible so what we do is if if a
student with the test wire is the next
thing is to do is to do some exercise so
we give a bunch of exercise to the model
I will give him roughly one million
exercise
there we attract to overfit the human
event so everything is a human evil
format
and and then and then this is what we
you get from from from the result so you
may ask that did we just accidentally
generate some human evil questions so
you can solve the human evil
so we do a lot of testing I'm not going
through this life but we do did some
serious testing to make sure we launch
your thing and and since even with the
common handmade data set the model still
behave really good but but at the end we
found a very good test there I find it
very funny
we realize the model after doing the
exercise you can do something that does
not appear in the exercise at all for
example we look at the the all the
exercise there is no problem related to
pie touch and Pi game so we can try
asking it is some question about those
package
um
and turns out amazingly it can do better
much better
uh I'm not going over details of those
examples but but you you have some lines
in showing off you have key game some
Ball moving around and then something
something and I asked it to generate and
this this is our final model this is
before seeing the exercise and you can
see
after seeing the exercise you can solve
those those uh Palms
but it doesn't appear in the exercise it
it's just kind of funny why after doing
exercise it it organizes knowledge to
something has nothing to do with
exercise somehow seems
or another way to explain this maybe the
model is just better at interesting
following it could be the annual reason
maybe it already know everything it just
don't know you need to follow the
instruction that could be the analysis
and then and then the most funny example
we have is this we we do some chat with
the model uh student I have a python Pi
pod I want to increase the resolution
and rotate the image
and then the model is somehow able to
answer it lightly after doing those
exercises this this has a different mode
the exercise database is just crashing
and answering in a particular format and
turns out we can do chat better after
doing exercise and we really don't have
good explanation of that
but
yeah so so our conclusion is
it seems uh you it is possible to get a
good small scale model for a narrow
topic
and and even for pre-training low cost
is possible like a few thousand dollars
yeah so so during the project one main
Theory question we want to answer but
don't know how to answer is this we have
we have the internet how can we tell
which part of the internet is good and
which is bad
Beyond just some heuristic like asking
GPT for
and and also what is the good schedule
of teaching the model is it better to
show him some textbook and show him some
exercise or or what is the ordering when
we are changing the model there is many
people telling us the best way to change
a model is first start with the unit
internet with those NLP data and then
change the coding part and in in our
paper we didn't do anything we just give
him the the data set and change it and
it worked well and we tried different
schedules since it doesn't matter too
much and but but what what type of
yeah I guess more generally what can we
talk about the science of data
for for llm
yeah that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh thank you for the great talk would
you like to comment on the stability of
the results like even for the math
um since different people may come up
with different answers and sometimes the
prompt may may change a lot or may not
so like when you uh work on those two
projects how do you find the sensitivity
of prompts or just different
temperatures affect the results so for
for GPT for one I think the
when when the model is good at something
then it is very robust under the problem
but for topic like math it
it doesn't really know math so it's
sometimes esthetically get the correct
answer or maybe that is just two three
few turns out
otherwise it's just lock opens because
it cannot do
but for our model our model isn't good
it our model if the Palm is slightly
more complicated it cannot solve for the
like wipe your shoulder with different
version of unicorn on everyday tracking
it seems they are not consistent in
terms of the shape of unicorn oh yeah oh
yeah no
no the current the public gpd4 cannot do
unicorns I would just ruin this one
yeah
so so you said it doesn't really quite
matter
such as you know when we teach um
teacher subject you know you start from
the simplest stuff first and then
so have you done any experiments so you
they will present the data in that order
foreign
but what about physics derivations you
know go to physics class they have
exercises they describe the situation
and ask you is that do you know I don't
like free sex
I mean I mean Ernie Davis and I just did
it we we gave a bunch of physics
problems you know it can often do well
at you know high school or undergrad
level physics problems not always but uh
yeah you can look at our examples if you
like
some evaluations have those two High
School physics science
isn't that really uninterest in this
point because like all of that high
school math physics chemistry there are
web pages that give the answers to every
question I mean you know I had kids
study Physics in Israel in physics in
the states in the states they give the
questions are the same as
is
the first explorer is because it's
abstract there's an abstraction to an
understanding
so look I mean I mean
I'm not very familiar with Hebrew Hebrew
physics questions
these days you look them up you don't
have to think the answer is sitting on a
web page and so it's a
it's of the general intelligence in my
opinion
can I ask a question about that topic I
mean
for this Sparks of general intelligence
I mean in some sense it seems that
you're a fairly random bunch of tasks
right I mean you know
drawing unicorn and ticks it's kind of
cute and it shows that it's got some
amazing competence from examples of uh
bizarre skill
um but it doesn't actually seem very
close to general intelligence I mean you
know are there are there kind of tasks
that
are much closer to a general
intelligence
tasks that would make more sense to be
exploring and I think that they have to
be tasks that have a novelty that you
can create very different things I mean
to throw one out there
um Stanford colleague Mike genesereth is
like this General game playing framework
where you sort of specify a set of rules
for a new game that no one has seen
before then you work out whether the
computer can learn a good strategy to
play it I mean that sort of feels to me
actually more like a test of general
intelligence yeah we did that again
campaign
in in the paper and
and I think it
so so few years ago there is some
standard Benchmark on RL on some test
based game so what we did is we fit
those games to the AI to see if it can
pay and and in general it can pay ish
but but if it make a mistake it it can
correct a few times after that it starts
repeating itself so it can learn one or
two steps a lot very long scale
yeah item Mark sorry I don't know who
you're calling him I had a more general
question it I didn't catch in the paper
that you'd set the temperature to zero
was that true for like all the
experiments in that paper then the
reason I'm asking is that it looks like
the model is fairly well calibrated as a
language
in terms of making good probabilistic
predictions in the next token so I would
expect something that shows randomly
would produce more typical results than
something that always chose the most
likely
yeah I agree it is calibrated we do some
testing on calibration and it worked
perfectly but somehow somehow you've if
we do temperature
okay first of all if the topic gpt4 is
good at temperature usually doesn't
matter too much
yes temperature usually doesn't matter
too much just we want it more
deterministic
yeah so so us being scientists we tend
to think about ill intelligence as being
able to do intelligent things given like
new sorts of definitions or new sorts of
environments but these sorts of things
are you know I mean they're they're
displaying a confidence that is like
pretty pretty shocked most people would
at least be very impressed they're
written the thought wouldn't call it
intelligence but the sorts of
experiments where you sort of say okay
let me give you some new definitions
blah blah blah let me formulate some new
sort of imagination some hypothetical
settings they could be these sorts of
things they are very different from what
is the
learning on and these are like very
different sorts of tasks that I think
like we're very biased towards these
this is our this is our competitive
advantage in life right this is what we
do for a living but but uh I don't think
other people would call that
intelligence like outside of Art
I just think yeah it's important it's
important that you know given some weird
hypothetical settings so yeah the
definition of intelligence is still
hotly debated but I think you have to
have in the definition of intelligence
that being able to cope with novel
scenarios
right
like uh this is something that is
maybe maybe one day to ask this question
is um is there in in this hockey debated
uh topic of what's intelligence uh
surely there's some classification of um
you know different levels of
intelligence in the sense that you know
you might say well memory is already an
important element but we saw that long
ago with computers or doing calculations
you know that that of course was done a
long time ago but now you know there's
competence of these basic tasks you know
where does that fit so is there is there
is there
sort of a accepted classification of uh
you know a hierarchy of tasks and and
you know within which one can one can
sort of say how well is are we doing so
far and what remains to be done
when these anthropologists try to do
this you know a century ago it's an
embarrassing effect but there was you
know some example where Samantha Paul
just goes to some place you know blah
blah blah but says okay hypothetical
there's a cruise in some town all of the
dogs are red
okay so who's John lives in this town
John has a dog what color is John's dog
I don't know go ask Sean and the first
time
good technical stuff isn't something
they encountered
but anyway wait I think those clients
are very controversial but I've never
been claims of things like counter
factuals as being this more advanced
form of intelligence I don't think
there's actually any well accepted and
well-based hierarchy not that I'm aware
of I mean it may be the simplest
hierarchy used you could say in most
stem Fields it's in high school or
undergrad and it's not in grad school
yet
you know like like we have this you know
hierarchy that we you know you know
emergently that we need to create and
you know in order to you know teach
these things right and it's you know
judged by the very highest highest
Android of being able to you know deal
with you know completely novel
situations and you know invent New
Concepts right it's fall short but you
know it's uh uh you know it is it is
usually able to do under you know you
know high school or undergrad level word
problems yeah so I remember like 20
years ago like back when these were all
just philosophical thought experiments
right like there was the quest the way
people put the question was suppose that
you could pass the touring test by just
you know having a gargantuan lookup
table that just cashed the answers to
all possible questions right would that
count would that be intelligence right
and it seems like the you know a more
modern version of of that question could
be like suppose that you know you've
trained on all the you know undergrad
physics problems on the internet right
and then it can solve a new well then
you're gonna say that well it's doing
that just just because of all the things
that it's already seen But if human
imagination does not suffice to like
invent a new undergrad physics problem
that it can't solve right then you know
you know is this training on everything
on the internet was that just a valid
way of getting
yeah so I think it's very complicated I
mean I think actually part of what's
become clear is that memory and pattern
matching is much more important to human
and other creatures intelligence than
anybody
is to realize so you know we shouldn't
underestimate the amount of human
intelligence as well that is memory and
pattern matching
um so I agree with that but it you know
clearly I'm not as bad as I've heard
people say things like this and I just
you know it's just I mean it's what you
know very well in high schools
just you know you know I'm pattern
matching but you know people are saying
here
yes
being able to algorithmically like
generate uh
if you had access to what you could
generate
you know much better models
and so I'm kind of reminded of like you
know it seems like
algorithmically generate
um how does certain simplicity
and these more complicated research
level at the same amount that is
um
last couple of quick comments or
questions
you know I just want to say that the
degrees of novelty and
I gave this recent query so you are in
2016 and teenager texting what kind of
abbreviations would you be using
get a list of 10 abbreviations but can
you guess the first one the first one is
Nar not a robot
kind of novelty
um train like the small model on a
narrow topic and it did seem to like do
very well do you think like training
can allow like certain abilities like
planning forever
yeah personally I I believe it's only a
very giant model to do those panning or
those abs actions I think the real
problem is can we create a data set that
contains those skill
and that seems very difficult
um
how much like when you add planning to
The Prompt how much does it increase
results because what I'm thinking is if
you have a kind of you ask the prompt
and then there's a middle step where it
can
basically from your problem figure out
which topic you're talking about like
not maybe politics and such an algorithm
or some procedure you don't have to
follow and inject that back into the
prompt
and it does like every time
I think you can introduce like for every
single prompt and algorithm it should
follow and it can like dynamically make
it and then hopefully that can actually
yes
this is just a
right
right okay
for coffee and we'll come back at 11AM
thank you
[Applause]